so this is 30
minutes or so into the movie oh it
smells great i hope you're hungry
all homemade everything you see on the
table is from the farm
how long did we shoot it for because
there were quite a lot of
shots yes but over a couple of days
i remember being nervous about breaking
because it did
seem really reliant on the rhythm of of
everyone but it actually was fine
because we'd rehearsed it a bit and
everyone had
dived in and was you know we were
committed yeah
i i i i like that it felt like that you
know that it felt like a machine
that way but it was um trying to think
yeah it was
it was a while we did we we did a lot of
um
of the whole scene from um different
angles quicker and
photographs look exactly like
photographs i like photographs mostly
sports photographers what kind of
paintings do you make lucy
ah uh well i i'm not an abstract artist
so that's in my favor
i will i will never forget our first
rehearsal of this
and us laughing like we
remember we got all got the like fit of
giggles and it was just the most
hilarious
thing i think i've ever we didn't even
shoot it but it was the rehearsal that
was just so
funny jake used to paint two of them and
that was fun
it's funny wasn't this scene pretty much
the only scene that we were worried
about continuity
on for a moment yeah oh my god
yeah i didn't really care all that much
i think that had to do with the prop
guys
again they were so committed to
everything like the candles needed to be
the right length
it's so tense and so funny at the same
time yeah yeah
like that painting of that girl sitting
in a field looking at a house
christina's world wyeth yes exactly
but without people how can a
picture of a field be sad without a sad
person looking
sad in the field
that's an interesting problem i yeah
i i i i i struggle with that
uh well i have some pictures of my work
if you'd like to see
them we had no idea that you were doing
this for the camera that day i was so
surprised when i watched this
a lot of what we were trying to do was
anticipate um
the movements that like who is going to
speak next because we were trying to
sort of like
as if this is somebody as if this was in
your head
you would know now you're going to speak
these are
hmm
let me just say that's a prophetic toe
fixture
[Laughter]
there's not a person in them feeling sad
or joyous or whatever other emotion you
said
well maybe think of yourself as
the person looking out at the scene you
might have to see me in them
the whole house was incredible actually
wasn't it oh my god
the whole film is so detailed especially
visually
we had the farmhouse and we couldn't
really afford anything
else so we started to work with
wallpaper and we were trying to find
wallpaper
we we looked at a lot of um old
photographs and we saw a lot of
wallpapers and pattern clothing and um
it felt um it it felt very beautiful
and very cluttered and complicated to us
and so we were trying to sort of
incorporate that into
into the production design you know
thinking about like when you're shooting
through
uh the the dining room into the living
room or
or vice versa that you would see both
sets of wallpapers and how they would
look
i remember saying to charlie it was like
having dinner with
uh ghosts like everybody was a ghost
yeah definitely yeah and how do you
interact how do you have dinner with it
with the group of ghosts
i suppose like that guy so lonely and
disconnected it really is like living
with ghosts isn't it if you don't deal
with your
crap in life it just exists in you as
ghosts and and kind of controls you and
that's
that does happen decade after decade
unless you look at it
it's just become so toxic jack tells us
there's been
lots of famous husband and wife isis
yeah yeah i i i guess there have been
some
uh pierre marie curie shared a nobel
prize in physics
even i've heard of them well i've heard
of her anyway radiation
radioactive radium yes i am so glad
jake has found someone won't you please
tell us the story of how you met so much
love straight mother and son
oh it's so tense it's so tense
it's so brittle and so funny because
it's kind of familiar isn't it
yeah i went with a friend to a barn near
campus
and turned out to be trivia night oh i
love this so far jake is crazy about
trivia we used to play the genius
edition of the
we used to play the genie's edition we
used to play
it's gina's edition oh i always thought
the word was
genius i've been saying it wrong all
these years goes to show
i'm no genus
no no genus is not
the same as genius a genus is a category
i always thought it was the genius
edition i told everyone you knew every
answer in the genius edition i was very
proud of that why didn't we get the
genes
you know what really changed this scene
for me is when we talked about it's
we're almost like
it's almost we're all in the same we are
at the same head it's all
one person's kind of fractured
experience of yeah
and and individual but mostly that we're
all kind of
continuing um it just allowed the rhythm
to change i think
when we continue yeah i i agree
he was very serious about the game which
i found i don't know
charming and oh his team was called
version of zybro version of eyebrows
right and i asked him who brethren was
basically so i could say something to
him
and he told me that brezhnev was a
soviet engineer
and uh uh uh uh uh uh uh a a general of
the section head secretary of the
communists
during the age of starvation nation
stagnation
anyway those team names drive me nuts
usually they all have them those teams
show offy
but like when the pieces of the machine
get like stuck
and there's like a stutter in the machi
in the in the machine of this one
head and and it and it was kind of chaos
and then the machine broke apart and
then it was trying to come back together
again yeah
i thought you said you were talking
about berezner
uh
yes that's true but we didn't talk
anymore after that
i i guess is what i meant
and i didn't know english watching that
now i really am
seeing in you jesse plemons the way
you're playing him it's almost
like there is it's like you're trying to
stop the voices in your head or
something like it's like a distanced
thing and you can't stop it i mean i
don't know whether it's intended but it
really
you can in watching it now it feels like
there is this um anymore like you can't
turn it off i can see it
like on the when we were shooting i i
didn't quite know what anyone was doing
because we were all just kind of getting
through it
but i really do see that now in like
little looks if they're kind of so
like you're just keeping it together but
it's so bloody subtle
the line that keeps popping up i'm
thinking of
ending things it's like it's losing
control of his
his puppets you know my girlfriend
wanted to leave
and jake blurted out could he have my
number
there you go jake it's about time
the rest was history that was like
six weeks ago god feels longer
feels like forever in a way
i can i can't even remember how long ago
it is
you